Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us today for our 78th episode!
BAU BAU!
I feel like any day we're gonna hit 100.
Any day now!
And that scares me.
Good good!
BAU BAU!
Well, we're not gonna hit 100 episodes of FUWAMOCO Morning just yet.
Not yet.
And well, there might be some Ruffians who are joining us for the first time today on our subreddit.
FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
Hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag!
Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Is your morning good so far, Ruffian?
Oh, I see all the hashtag hashtags as usual, so I think it's off to a good hashtag hashtag after FWMCMORNING.
Is that how it works?
I don't know.
BAU BAU!
Well, Moco-chan, what kind of news do we have this morning?
Well... First off,
There's been another Pero Sighting.
I thought you wanna know.
I'll break the news to you quickly.
This is the report we got, Ruffians, okay?
Prepare yourself.
Don't be tricked, okay?
Even if you know you find what looks like a cute little puppy abandoned at the side of the road in an old wet cardboard box, don't give in, okay?
That's not a puppy, Ruffians.
That's Pero.
A very, very nasty demon dog.
No matter what kind of puppy dog eyes he gives you,
You really, really don't want to, okay?
No.
Ruffians, do you not remember what happened to those brothers many FUWAMOCO mornings back when they spotted Pero?
Do you remember?
The brothers.
I do.
I remember.
That was a good warning.
Yeah.
No!
Oh no, you have to remember.
You're in trouble, okay?
No, you don't want to end up like that.
Yeah, you remember and you see that.
What happened to you, okay?
Okay, so if you decide to take him in, that could be you.
That could?
Yeah.
And that would be bad, okay?
That would?
Right!
So, don't, okay?
Just don't.
Really don't want you.
Really, really don't.
Okay.
I guarantee you, Ruffians!
Guarantee it!
It has the FUWAMOCO guarantee, okay?
Yeah.
We're FUWAMOCO, okay?
Listen, use your ears.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians!
What else about you?
We wanted to share a scoop that we got from a Ruffian who's very infamous in the knowhow.
Thank you, TK-san, for the impeccable journalism!
Impeccable!
Well, it seems like Advent's first original song, Rebellion, premiered on a debut six months ago.
It has now hit 3 million views on the official hololive English YouTube channel!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much to all the Ruffians and Adventrix who've been listening to it over and over and over.
It's a very special song to us.
You know, it's filled with lots of hopes and dreams.
Also, Mama Puppy loves it too, okay?
Mama Puppy seal of approval.
Exactly.
FUWAMOCO, we really hope that one day maybe we can sing it for you live all together as Advent.
All five of us!
What do you think of that, Ruffian?
Fun!
Fire, fire, light the fire!
Dance, dance, dance!
We'll be fun.
We'll have to look forward to that day and just continue to listen to Rebellion more and more and more.
Be prepared, okay?
BAU BAU!
Get ready to dance!
Yeah, atarashii sekai e kitto.
New world.
Right.
Ruffians!
I actually, actually, I actually have some happy, happy news!
But, well, it's not for me.
Moco-chan.
Happy news for you, right?
Wow.
For the first time, instead of making Rat King tea, you know with my leftover tea bags, there was a lot of them.
I threw them all out and started the Ruffians while I did it!
I did Ruffians!
I did for you!
I tossed them all in the trash!
I saw!
You know, I also figured,
We might have gotten a bit strange since the pile had gotten pretty big.
It was really big.
And you know, we still have a lot of new tea bags left on the pantry too, so I thought maybe this time it will be okay.
This time?
This time.
Are you proud of me, Ruffians?
Wait, Moco-chan!
I thought that you said that there'll be no more Rat King tea, right?
This time.
Pride!
Super pride!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU.
Good announcement, huh?
It's a start.
BAU BAU!
Well, Ruffians, that aside, I guess, next week is Valentine's Day!
And, well, as you might know, FUWAMOCO, we really enjoy spending the holidays together with you.
I'm surprising you too!
Surprises.
It's gonna be a fun holiday.
Fun.
Holiday surprises.
Holidays!
Oh, you know, we've been working on some special things behind the scenes for it.
You know, we're pretty excited, but also pretty nervous too!
Yeah, because you know, it'll be our first Valentine's Day together.
But,
Ruffians.
I do want you to know that officially, you know us, FUWAMOCO, we will not be making our ASMR debut during this holiday period.
Understood.
Okay, Ruffians.
Let's- Let's all say a big- Oh, no!
Together, okay.
Alright, get out of the system.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, Ruffians.
Three, two, one.
Oh, no!
Yeah.
Too bad.
Wait!
Huh?
What?
Wait.
One day.
One day?
Really?
Yeah.
This year!
We will make our ASMR debut.
Maybe.
This year.
Today not today.
Not today.
Not tomorrow.
Maybe one day.
Maybe this year.
Yeah, but Ruffians, you know, if you're a little sad about it, that's okay.
That's okay, it's okay to be sad sometimes.
Maybe we can suggest to you our Valentine's voice pack.
Right?
This should make you fluffy and fuzzy again, right?
Right!
At the very least, you know, our Valentine's week, I don't know, is looking pretty busy.
So, please make time for us if you can, okay?
Got it!
BAU BAU!
Wow, Ruffians.
On the topic of voice packs and all those kinds of things.
You know, we thought, especially with Advent's 6th birthday anniversary, and you know, our birthdays, and we have Valentine's coming up, and much more, that we thought you might be feeling a little bit overwhelmed.
I'm feeling a bit overwhelmed.
I am too, actually.
You know, cause all of a sudden, there's been
A lot of FUWAMOCO news.
A lot!
Right!
All of a sudden!
It feels like within a week!
Right!
Yeah, you are definitely- We're very happy!
We're very excited!
Very excited!
It makes sense, you know?
Yeah.
But, uh...
Guys, we were thinking about you.
And thought that it might just be a bit confusing.
About, you know, what to get and what to prioritize, you know.
We realize it's difficult and it's all different.
Yeah, there's a lot of different types of merch.
We wanted to let you know our thoughts about each item.
Thinking not only from our level of excitement for things.
But you know, also taking into factor the type of merchandise, the pre-order window, limited stock of each item, and what not, you know.
Not only from our perspective, but from our fan perspective too, okay?
You don't know that this is something that we wanted to do.
We're excited and we wanted to help you out with everything so you don't miss out.
No skip ad, okay?
We're excited.
We wanted to do this, okay?
You know, also, we're sure that there's so much that you don't even know out there that's available, okay?
It's all just all of a sudden.
Watch us!
We're gonna go through it together, okay?
We broke it down, okay?
Yeah, because you know, FUWAMOCO, we're really a big fan!
Please let us help you out, okay?
Let's go do it all here.
First, we have our birthday merch!
If you have not heard about it, we are very excited!
It's our birthday merch.
Yeah, our first birthday merch ever.
First up is Fuwawa here, in case you couldn't tell.
I have my duolude acrylic paddle with a beautiful illustration by Miwabe Sakura-sensei.
And this is
Moco-chan's is a little different.
We're twins, but a little different.
It also comes with a Ruffian, plus she's so cute!
We're very excited about them!
Okay.
Big recommendation.
Like, oh, I can fit it on my desk.
Nope!
He is big.
He's big.
He's a big... Good to hug!
Yeah.
Okay.
And then we have my t-shirt.
You know, the spring's coming up, the summer's coming up.
A good way to say I like Fuwawa.
Right?
But it's not too, like, in your face.
And then we have a very cute acrylic keychain.
You know, maybe you have, like, a cute new bag you want to accessorize.
This would be the perfect thing.
And well, we also have a voice prank.
A voice adventure with me, Fuwawa.
Don't you want to go on a voice adventure with Fuwawa?
And because it's English and Japanese, so you know double the fun.
I have my acrylic diorama stand.
Diorama stand.
Whichever one you want.
And the illustration is by Aoki Ume-sensei!
You might recognize.
Hidamari Sketch.
Madoka Magikai.
I'm really excited.
I'm not gonna cry this time.
Big recommendation show!
Tickets for BAU!
Ruffian plushie!
Big, big, big, big, big, big recommendation, okay!
Really, really big, okay!
You'll hear more later.
And then my T-shirt!
T-shirt!
You know, this is also FUWAMOCO's first T-shirt, right?
I mean, we had the Halloween one, but that was with Abyss.
But this is just mine.
Why?
So you know, I know there's three days of the week, you know, FUWAMOCO, but you could wear Fuwawa shirt, Mococo shirt, and then
Wednesday is Advent.
Oh, so Friday Fuwawa shirt, Wednesday Advent shirt, and then Monday Mococo shirt!
Exactly!
And then, my kitchen!
You know it could be very cute on a bed along with Fuwawas too.
Double accessories!
You know, maybe you'll have a best friend.
Twiddies!
And then my play spot!
You wanna cook some stuff together?
Donuts!
Maybe a little secret, Ruffians?
I don't like the oil, so I need your help, okay?
BAU BAU!
And it's in English and Japanese too, okay?
We cannot stress how excited we are about our birthday merch.
But next!
Like a day early, it was announced with a 6 month anniversary Advent Happy New Year celebration merch!
And for this, we have the Tapestry.
Very cool.
It's good if you like a bit more of a hardcore looking.
FUWAMOCO, we're cute, fluffy, fuzzy, but this is more on the
And then we also have the metal keychains.
Again, if you want us to protect your keys by, uh...
Maybe the acrylic one is a bit too white for you.
This is heavy.
Hardcore.
Everyone's gonna question you.
And I forgot to mention!
So, our birthday goods!
Important.
Sales stop March 4th.
Now, we have our limited birthday goods, but they already sold out.
But the regular sales stopped.
in about a month.
And same with the advent goods.
Sales also stop.
March 4th.
JST.
Yeah, there's still time, but just don't forget, okay?
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO!
When we're excited about something, but then we get a bit too excited and we're like, okay, well, I'll do that soon.
Especially with purchases, we forget.
I like to put everything off until it's gone.
That is what I do.
Don't be like FUWAMOCO, okay?
I don't want you to be disappointed, okay?
And next, we have our Valentine's Day goods.
Now these are a bit different, because there's no order period.
They are limited until they're sold out.
Which, well, if any Ruffians, if you're interested in making like a ita bag, so you have a whole bunch of the badges, the cat badges, well, unfortunately, FUWAMOCO's individual... But happily!
Yeah, happily!
Thank you!
The individual badges are now sold out.
But, dare I say!
So you can still get them, but if you're thinking of making an itabag, you might have a lot of sets from here on out.
A lot of hand towels.
Hippopo sets.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Yeah, maybe, you know, you want to give hand towels to every family member?
Well, you could get a lot of sets then, right?
I like Advent.
I like Advent!
So yeah, these are a bit different.
There's not a sales period that ends.
It's just when they're gone, they're gone.
They're gone, they're gone.
But!
More importantly!
We have a Valentine's voice pack!
You know, it came out at the same time as our birthdays, so... You know, we haven't really talked about it too much, but... We were tired of it!
We did!
And you know, we worked on the script ourselves.
I think it came out cutely.
We have a crazy bunch of lines.
I'm sure there's a lot of Ruffians saving it for Valentine's Day.
That makes sense.
We're really working hard on voice packs, you know, as a way to grow, a way to challenge ourselves.
If you could, we'd really like that!
Okay, we're doing our best.
Moco-chan, does this have a sales period?
It ends on April 8th, okay?
You might think the voice packs don't.
They don't stop.
But this one ends April 8th.
So if you're interested in a bit of a different, Valentines-y side to FUWAMOCO, this might be for you, okay?
Continuing!
At the New Year's!
We had Advent New Year's merchandise.
We had our voice drama, a very huge one of New Year's.
And we also had the hololive closet acrylic stand.
Now, I would say that these are very high priority, but
They are available for the foreseeable future.
Not limited, not a certain sales period.
So, you can pick them up when you want, I believe.
Okay!
It's too much!
I know that's why we're trying to help you, okay?
I'm excited!
They get restocked, I believe so!
I'm not certain, but I believe so!
But if you haven't picked up a birthday merch, and you haven't picked up these, well... It's a good opportunity, right?
But, there is also... Ah, mine.
But also!
I got Moco-chan!
Also!
What is this?
FUWAMOCO, we're participating in the Lantern Festival in Kainan!
In case you haven't seen, we shared it on Twitter, but we haven't really shared it much elsewhere.
It hasn't started yet.
It has not started.
It starts February 24th until March 10th, so two week period.
There is a lot of merch in there!
Really exciting merch!
I'm only gonna show you a couple items that we're very very excited about, but there is
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
Maybe, maybe.
But FUWAMOCO, together with the senpai, we're very cute.
Very styled, right?
We have the full print t-shirt.
And then, we also have plushies.
Plushies!
Look!
Look at us in our little dragon costume.
Very, very cute.
We've seen stuff.
They're very, very cute.
Okay.
Very, very cute.
And then, we got charms!
Charms!
Like, a goal, a debut, right, Moco-chan?
Yeah.
We're happy!
And they're so cute!
They're so cute!
Blue and pink.
Yeah.
Right.
And then also, this one's surprising.
We were surprised.
Candy!
Candies!
But it's not just, you know, not just packaging.
It's our faces.
Our faces.
In the candy.
I wonder what- Oh, can you compare our flavors to a senpai?
I wonder.
Yes!
Candy!
Like actual candy!
Yes!
It's very exciting!
You can't eat FUWAMOCO just this occasion.
It's very limited and might be difficult to get at the Ruffians.
If you can't actually go to the festival, well, you might need to ask a friend to go and get it for you.
And that might be the hard part.
There's a lot of other items too, so you'll have to check it out.
We will tweet more about it after FUWAMOCO Morning.
It hasn't started yet, don't worry.
You still have time to find your friend, okay?
That is everything!
Our merch!
The merch!
It all came out really suddenly!
It's overwhelming, huh?
So, if you're still feeling overwhelmed, here we go.
Summary.
We have a priority score here.
So, first, birthday.
If we could do 10 stars, we would do 10 stars, okay?
We could do 100?
We would do 100 stars, okay?
Because it's limited until March 4th, you know?
It's a small period.
It's FUWAMOCO's first birthday match!
We put a lot of love into it.
I hope that you'll love it too.
And after that, we have Advent's 6 month print.
It also ends March 4th DST.
Heavily recommended to those Adventrix maybe.
Don't you have multiple OSHI with an Advent?
Go for it.
Valentine's!
Also very good.
Also limited.
Don't forget, okay?
Put the Valentine's voice pack!
We're really working hard.
We will be really happy, okay?
And I think it's cute.
It's cute.
I think it's cute!
And you know, Ruffians if you're a little bit like, oh but shipping!
Waste Pack.
No shipping!
And then, Advent New Year!
Very exciting, but you know, it's there for a while for this foreseeable future, so you don't need to rush.
Low priority.
Lantern Festival!
Really cool merch!
Really cool, really cute!
Might be hard to get your paws on.
Okay.
So, the final, the final, what is it?
Conclusion!
If your wallet could is really crying, and you can only get one thing.
Yeah, maybe you've never bought merch before.
It's a bit scary.
What would we recommend, Moco-chan?
Ruffian plushies!
Okay.
Talk to Marnie-chan.
Yeah.
I don't know how many we are ordering.
Mari-chan said, no FUWAMOCO, you need to order your own.
We can't get that many extras.
Makes sense.
It's too many extras.
Okay.
You don't want to hug?
It makes sense.
It's too much.
After the first one is tired.
It's too many, okay.
Okay.
I hope you understand.
Also!
After the Ruffian plays his birthday, okay?
No!
Birthday!
Very exciting.
Do you feel a little less overwhelmed, Ruffians?
Why do you just feel overwhelmed like I yelled at you for a long time, huh?
It was a great reminder!
We did it for your sake, okay?
Thank you.
And because I'm excited!
BAU BAU!
This was FUWAMOCO's comprehensive merch priority guide.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Mococo's stressing you out!
I'm not stressing you out!
But... Wow, if Moco-chan stressed you out... Wow, Moco-chan.
Can you fix the situation?
Uh, I can't promise anything, but I'll do my best, okay?
Ruffians!
You know what day it is.
Today is Night Time of Week!
It's time for you to lend me your ear, because this here is a Mococo Pup Talk!
Good one, right?
And you're gonna hear it straight from me, Mococo!
Ruffians!
Hello!
I know it's still just the morning and that the day is just starting, but I wanted to see it anyway.
Good job on all your hard work recently!
Okay.
Hmm.
Yeah!
All your heartbreak!
Everyday, yeah!
I know.
I know!
Even when you take a bit of a break!
That's just a breather!
Rest is just as important as your work.
You know?
So don't deny yourself it!
And recently, uh... You've treated us, FUWAMOCO, sorta like
Princesses.
Why?
Cuz it was our birthdays!
So... How about it?
It's time to treat yourself like royalty!
Every now and again too, okay?
But...
You know, you have to take care of yourself and your heart before you can take care of others, okay?
So, let's make sure to keep ourselves happy so that we can help those around us too.
Got it?
Keep doing your best!
I know you can do it!
We're both here to help you, okay?
We're here with you!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU!
Don't feel overwhelmed, Ruffians!
Keep on going!
Did that count as me yelling at you still?
I hope not.
BAU BAU!
Well, let's see who the Doggie of the Day is today!
Our Doggie of the Day is De-den!
The Doggie of the Day is me!
BAU BAU!
This must be the biggest Doggie of the Day we've ever had, huh?
Is this one of those mastiffs?
Or a St.
Bernard's?
Maybe, maybe.
It could be!
Well, you know, even though Max is on the bigger size, he still loves playing together with his family outside.
Very nice!
And actually, he loves his veggies too!
It's good to be health conscious, doggie, huh?
Very good.
It's good to be health conscious.
Yeah, great day.
Well, how does Max BAU BAU?
BAU!
That may be.
It's a bit of a different BAU BAU than FUWAMOCO, huh?
He is very big, so... Yeah.
Makes sense.
Yeah, big BAU BAU.
Yeah, Max?
Max is bigger than the other doggies.
But he doesn't let that get in his way of having fun!
No, he's gonna have fun!
Yeah, he loves his family more than anything!
And he's such a gentle soul!
You know, I think...
I think he'll even share his veggies with you, too.
That's nice.
Yeah.
You know, he wants you to be healthy and happy for many years to come, too, so... Nice.
Kaimasu.
BAU BAU!
Next, Moco-chan, for our Today I Went On A Walk, we have De-den!
Sunset.
It's beautiful.
And such a wonderful friend you have too!
Right.
Please keep them close by your side, okay?
That's a good thing.
We hope that you can enjoy even more lovely walks together.
Right, a walk!
This is a walk!
This is their walk!
Oh my gosh.
Too pretty.
You need to go on lots of walks, okay?
Because I'm envious.
Okay.
I treasure it!
BAU BAU!
For our Question of the Day, today we have de-den!
So, where did you two learn the word 'yobai' from?
Ruffians!
Have you been wondering about this too?
Where do you think that we learned about this word, huh?
Huh?
Hi.
No.
No!
I'm a proper demon dog, okay?
Don't misunderstand.
Yeah.
Wow.
FUWAMOCO!
You know, probably by now that we know lots of things about Japanese culture and language.
And that's because we had serious classes as a part of our Demon Guardian training.
Yeah, not puppy classes, okay?
Seriously, the course is pretty popular.
And so you know, we landed there doing training in a very structured setting, talking about Japanese history and culture and all that.
That's how.
You know, that's why it's my favorite Japanese word.
Because it's really interesting and culturally important in history.
That's why.
Okay.
Yo, no, no, no!
Demon guide dog tweeting, not your...
What?!
No.
Ruffians.
User brains.
They're there.
I believe in you.
This is a Mococo pup talk.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Got it.
No misunderstanding.
Yeah.
How can you?
How?
We were training to be demon guard dogs to protect your smile.
Very serious, okay?
Very serious.
We worked hard.
We did.
And now we're here.
BAU BAU.
I'm happy to be here.
As long as you use your brain.
Look at it!
We have another stream coming up, right Moco-chan?
Well, today... Not today, because today we're gonna be blasting through some serious homework today, right?
So, please wish us luck.
But tomorrow, tomorrow we'll be playing a very cute co-op game together called Bread and Fred!
I don't know why their names are Bread and Fred.
I don't know.
We'll find out, huh?
We'll find out, but I think, you know, it's gonna be perfect for twin demigod dogs like us who have lots of training.
Training to be Bread and Fred?
No.
We're FUWAMOCO!
We hope that you'll join us, Ruffians, for lots of silliness, okay?
BAU BAU!
It's our schedule!
Well, you might see that before the next FUWAMOCO Morning, we'll have our first co-op ever with AZKi-san!
And well, we're gonna be playing Geoguessr together with her on her channel!
So we hope that maybe you'll set your alarm clock
A few hours earlier!
It's a bit early.
Yeah, I'm not gonna be able to join us for that.
Okay!
We're really looking forward to it!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you!
And with that, today's FUWAMOCO Morning comes to an end.
Thank you so much for joining us today for our info session!
Hopefully I didn't yell your ear off high.
I need you to keep your ear
Well, before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Kurocha!
BAU BAU!
Diego!
Gengen!
BAU BAU!
Lim!
Moriari!
BAU BAU!
Squib.
Kirari.
BAU BAU!
Lori.
Thomas.
BAU BAU!
Wizery.
Hiyuki BAU BAU!
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!